hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today undermining the
UK's climate commitments criticism after
Michael Gove gives the go-ahead to the
First new coal mine for 30 years the
Pro's development itself would have an
overall neutral effect on climate change
and as such there would be no material
comfort with government policies for
meeting the challenge of climate change
also ahead how wood burners can be up to
4 000 times more polluting than gas
Central Heating and fears grow over
whether the Nations involved in the
cop-15 biodiversity Summits will be able
to agree a pact to protect nature for
this decade
[Music]
hi welcome to the Daily climate show
where we track the changes to our world
and investigate some of the potential
solutions to The Climate crisis now
after two years of touring and throwing
the government last night gave the green
lights to a new Coal Mine in Whitehaven
in Cumbria that campaigners insist there
is nothing green about it at all and
question how the commitment to Net Zero
can in any way be compatible with
building the first coal mine in the UK
for 30 years the government argues that
if anything the country's carbon
footprint will be reduced as the coking
coal which will be used for the steel
making industry will replace coal that
would otherwise have to be imported our
science editor Tom Clark reports
this former industrial site is about to
become home to the UK's first new Coal
Mine in 30 years
the proposed Woodhouse colliery aims to
produce coal for the steel industry from
a seam extending from this protected
Cumbria Coastline far out under the
Irish sea the local Council couldn't be
happier we've waited a long time for it
the community have waited a long time to
eat so we believe it's the right
decision it's the right thing for us
here the hard work that's gone in from
our community and support in this our
local Council that's all now been
recognized and I'm I'm delighted that
the government have Now supported this
decision West Cumbria mining the
australian-backed company behind it
promises 500 local jobs but what of the
global impact of the three million tons
of coal each year they will produce the
government's perfectly logical view is
that because our steel makers currently
import coking coal and will continue to
do so the impact of a local mine on
climate would be neutral or even
beneficial if you follow the logic of
this decision through it either means
that this coal mine will only operate
for a limited amount of time because our
steel industry has to reach Net Zero by
about 2035 according to the government's
advisors or that the government's
prepared to pass on its carbon-cutting
obligations to Future governments and
future Generations
local campaigners are in disbelief
they've heard all the evidence they've
seen the results for themselves they've
been and seen the communities that have
been flooded out as a result already of
global warming
and they're going ahead with coal mine
it's just
yeah really really upset and really
disappointed
what does it also say about our
International rhetoric on climate it's a
terrible decision it's a terrible
decision for our energy policy for our
climate policy and it won't provide the
jobs that people in Cumbria need they've
come up with a solution which is going
to make us make a mockery of us
internationally which senior
conservatives have said is the wrong
decision it's a government that is out
of ideas and that is stuck in the past
the last mine in this town closed in
1986 and now a new coal era begins but
in a world that's more than half a
degree warmer than it was then and
getting warmer all the time Tom Clark
Sky News Whitehaven
well the man who gave the go-ahead for
the new mine is the leveling up housing
and communities secretary Michael Gove
he has been defending his decision today
the applicant is making it clear that
this will be the only Net Zero
metallurgical cooking coal mine in the
world
[Applause]
and it is vitally important that all of
us recognize
as the inspector does on page 255 that
the proposed development would to some
extent support the transition to a
low-carbon future is specifically as a
consequence of the provision of a
currently needed resource from a mine
that aspires to be Net Zero I think it
is also important that we recognize that
in any change of uh land use there will
always be a potential impact on
biodiversity and on the local
environment as well and again it is
important to denote that the inspector
on page 278 of his uh report makes it
clear that this mind would not cause any
unacceptable impacts on ecology nor
result in a net loss in biodiversity
uh and they expect to also makes clear
in paragraph 22.9 that the Pro's
development itself would have an overall
neutral effect on climate change and as
such there would be no material conflict
with government policies for meeting the
challenge of climate change
a report from England's chief medical
officer has found that eco-designed wood
burning stoves produce 450 times more
toxic air pollution than gas Central
Heating and to Chris witty's report
found that older heat is now banned from
sale produced nearly 4 000 times more
air pollution while electric heating
produces none
Professor which is report also calls on
people to have the courage to tell
motorists to stop idling engines as part
of efforts to tackle pollution air
pollution was chosen by circus as the
focus of his 2022 annual report he said
there has been progress in tackling
outdoor air pollution over the years and
that is set to continue but outdoor air
pollution still leads to between 26 and
38 000 deaths a year in England alone
Rising temperatures driven by climate
breakdown are causing distress to the
fetuses of pregnant Farmers a study
revealed the fetuses of women working in
fields in The Gambia showed concerning
rises in heart rates and reductions in
the blood flow to the placenta as
conditions became hotter there's already
strong evidence that extreme heat leads
to increases in stillbirths premature
births and low birth weights in Rich
temperate countries the new study
focuses on farmers in a tropical country
where increasing extreme heat is a
serious concern
in Montreal where the cop 15
biodiversity Summit is currently taking
place fears are said to be growing over
whether the 190 countries involved could
agree on an ambitious Global pact to
protect nature this decade the formal
negotiations have now begun but extra
talks before the opening of The Summit
failed to streamline the draft
biodiversity targets the UN Secretary
General Antonio guterres has urged the
participating Nations to resolve their
differences
climate action and protection of
biodiversity are two sides of the same
coin
and we need tough regulatory Frameworks
and disclosure measures the attend green
washing and all the private sector
accountable
and we need developed countries to
provide meaningful financial support for
the countries of the global South as
gustavians of the world's natural wealth
following centuries of exploitation and
loss
the executive director of business for
nature is heading to the summit so
tomorrow and joins us now from Geneva
thank you for your time today all this
is really a trade-off isn't it being
considered between people and
conservation which is winning
well it shouldn't be a trade-off at all
in fact none of us can live without all
of the natural resources that our
precious Planet provides so you know
thriving economies and healthy societies
thriving businesses all fundamentally
rely on nature and so that's why this
conference is so important the UN
climate cops is something that we're
familiar with now what's happening in
Montreal as you just said all of these
governments coming together to negotiate
and hopefully adopt What's called the
global biodiversity framework as part of
the sister biodiversity cop and just
like the Paris agreement on climate we
now need an ambitious Global
biodiversity framework and the reason
that I'm saying that is because
businesses need the political certainty
to then scale and speed up action and if
we're really honest about it
unfortunately the voluntary actions are
just not enough to address the scale of
nature loss we're seeing and that has
impacts on people of course which should
be Central to these decisions
I should say then that because the
voluntary actions are not are not enough
what's happening now is that more than
330 companies and financial institutions
from 52 countries are calling for
mandatory requirements for all large
businesses and financial institutions to
both assess and disclose their impacts
and dependencies on nature so that's a
key element for us in that Global
biodiversity framework because without
this information yeah sorry I'm digging
right in there yeah they're really going
to get involved in this these businesses
then
they are and we've actually seen
tremendous momentum like never before
it's really unprecedented hundreds of
companies now finally seeing nature on
their business agenda alongside the
political one now these all of these
political decisions and Frameworks only
are impactful if they lead to action and
we can only take meaningful action if we
have the information so right now we
don't even have the information when we
say we it's even governments consumers
businesses investors don't have the
right information of the impacts and
dependencies that lead to risks and
opportunities for for all of us and so
that's why we're essentially Flying
Blind and it's completely normal to
require businesses to report on their
financial performance we now need there
be there to be mandatory requirements to
report on natural social and human
capital too
on a scale of one to ten how optimistic
are you that this Summit can achieve
anything previous commitments have
really not been met have they
that's and
if that point really tricky question
because a lot of the discussions are
actually quite up in the air right now
there are some positive signs of
discussions moving forward but again
um it's a bit too early to say I remain
optimistic that there will be
an agreement
um especially I think what's needed now
is that high level political leadership
coming in and so the there are over a
hundred ministers that are planning to
come to cop15 next week that needs to
unblock some of the negotiations
um on the ground
but it regardless of an agreement I
would just add I think that the momentum
that the cop 15 has provided as a hook
for realizing yes we need that high
policy ambition at a global level that
will then be implemented at a national
level and will set the bar that bar
needs to be set High to level the
playing field for all companies
um and essentially the message that
we're going in with hundreds of
companies that are ready for the change
is business as usual is no longer an
option and we need large-scale action
that can only happen if all elements of
the system's transformation are in place
so businesses don't operate in isolation
they operate within multiple systems
that we all as individuals are part of
with how we spend our time our money and
who we vote for for example all right
well we'll see what happens with me Eva
is Abby great to talk to you thanks for
your time
thank you
and that is it from us today just a
reminder though you can watch Tom heaps
climate show on Saturdays and Sundays at
3 30 in the afternoon and again it's 7
30 in the evening
and if you have questions about climate
change that you want answered then send
them all to us using this QR code and we
will try to answer as many as we can on
Tom's show but that's it for now and
from me thanks for watching bye
[Music]